[Music]
Poliomyelitis, a disease that has
affected human beings since the
beginning of civilization,
was already known 3,000 years ago, as we
can see in this Egyptian hieroglyph
that describes the affliction of a
priest of the time, this disease is
caused by a virus that  It affects the
central nervous system,
frequently producing paralysis and in some
cases death.
Large epidemics of polio have caused
countless cases of paralysis,
especially in infants. Throughout history,
the first step towards its conquest was
taken in 1908 by
researchers Landsteiner and Popper.  In
1949, scientists
Enders Robbins
and Weller discovered that
poliovirus could be propagated through human cultures.
A few years later, in 1953,
Dr. Jonas Shock reported that
humans could be effectively immunized
using inactivated poliovirus,
later in 1962.  doctor albert
sailing developed a
poly vaccine  ovirus gdp that could
now be administered at 20,
dramatically contributing to the reduction of
this disease
We have now entered a new
period in the fight against this
disease, the goal this time is its
complete elimination from the American continent
for this reason on May 14  In 1985, at
the headquarters of the Pan American
Health Organization, international agencies,
government representatives, volunteer organizations,
as well as a large number of individuals and
institutions related to
public health, met, coordinating their efforts to
eradicate poliomyelitis between now and
1990 from the Americas on this occasion.
Dr. Carlisle Guerra de Macedo,
Director of the Pan-American
Health Organization, announced that I am pleased to extend
a warm welcome to the
distinguished scientists,
political leaders, and members of the
diplomatic corps who today with their
presence at the
Pan-American Health Organization and who  when
appearing  In this act, to reaffirm
once again the solidarity commitment
made to fight the disease at all costs
in the Americas In the
Americas each year there is a loss of
800,000 children under one year of age who
die from causes that can be prevented
with relatively common medicines and technologies.
Already available
among these technologies, immunization
is one of the most effective and efficient.
We have vaccines to prevent 6
diseases: measles, diphtheria,
tetanus, whooping cough, tuberculosis, and
poliomyelitis.
We have managed to extend coverage to
60 percent of children in the
Americas.  exposed to the risk of contracting
these diseases and we have managed to
reduce the number of victims of
poliomyelitis, the time has come
for us to resolve once and for all
with the threat of this disabling disease
that still hung over the children of
the Americas until it was  lies the
poliovirus the danger of
sudden outbreaks of poliom  ielitis will continue
to exist the only sure way to
protect our children against the
spectrum of polio is to
eradicate the virus of this
disease from our continent with the
help of all it is feasible to interrupt
the autochthonous transmission of
wild poliovirus in the continent by 1990
we firmly believe  that it is possible
to reduce the annual number of cases to zero
and we propose that the
member governments of the
Pan American Health Organization be given all the
necessary support to achieve the eradication of
poliomyelitis before the Americas
in a massive and final joint effort
Over the next five years
the time has come to declare
that it is unacceptable for any child in
the Americas to suffer from polio
[Applause]